what frustrates you the most about
filmmaking
it's it's kind of the best and the worst
thing about it it's the fact
that you have to rely on so
many factors and people and
circumstances outside of your control
you know and i think what's different
about
filmmaking as opposed to painting is
you know i can go in my room i can paint
nobody has to bother me i don't have to
worry about the train going by and
making noise i don't have to worry about
the sunset
you know i control everything
essentially you know
with filmmaking if we don't show up
at the little window of time where the
sun is perfect and the
traffic's not too loud and the you know
dog walkers aren't out in full force and
we have the location the way we want
like it's such a weird like specific
thing you're going for in film
um but that's also why i love it because
you know i love
working with people i love communicating
ideas even if it you know you have to
butt heads a little bit to get to that
end result you know it's always worth it
because
it's a giant collaboration and as much
as i do
on my own with filmmaking i don't ever
want to do a film truly on my own
unless i just have to but i always enjoy
working with someone
you know whether the crew is three
people or 30 i've done both
and i always enjoy working with people
to problem solve and it's
it's truly like a puzzle like one of my
favorite
video games is tetris and i think that's
like by design because i always love
problem solving and i think that
you know as creative as filmmaking is
there is that like
slight and analytical component to it
with the problem solving
so anything that frustrates you about
filmmakers
yeah i i think and i mean we're all
guilty of it but i think
filmmakers sometimes we tend to think a
little too much about
ourselves and our films our
crews our characters rr and i think we
forget like what is the landscape of
this general industry looking like
what are we leaving behind um how are we
ushering in the next generation of
filmmakers are we
sticking out our hand are we turning our
back and
i've had a lot of backs turned on me
like when i first got in this industry
like when i worked on some of the bigger
you know crew sets
on tv shows and i did some reality shows
pa works and stuff like that
like i was telling people i was writing
a feature and they were like you're
never gonna make that like people would
say that to my face like you're never
gonna make that if you think you can
make it for two thousand dollars you're
crazy
you're gonna burn out i wouldn't
recommend it don't do that
i heard no so many times and
while i knew it was going to be a
challenge i also was cognizant enough to
think
okay this maybe isn't the best look for
the industry and i'm not saying
that's a you know broad brush for sure
but a lot of times i think that we're
all so focused on what we are doing
we're not thinking about
kind of the general landscape out there
does it look
inviting uh does it welcome anyone new
in or is it the same people doing the
same thing because we're all just kind
of taking
what we can and if you realize that you
have to ask
why is that happening and you know
sometimes you can't fault people for
you know trying to make their film
because it's hard it really is hard
and you know a lot of times there's not
a lot of room
and not a lot of uh pie left on the
plate if you will
for thinking about the future and
thinking about everyone else but it's
something i try to do you know anytime i
have a film
in production i try to reach out to like
the local high schools and colleges and
film schools
and get the people there involved and
try to like
show them that you know hey this isn't
super glamorous but it's possible and if
you ever need help
seriously give me a call i'll hold a
boom pole i'll do what i can
like it's that kind of like just small
effort and it can really only be made on
a person-to-person basis
um you know i can't do that for everyone
in the whole filmmaking landscape
but just kind of reaching out to others
who may be you know hitting the same
walls you were hitting when you started
in the industry i think is is really
crucial
do you think sometimes though early
rejection is almost a blessing
it is yeah i think when you are rejected
it forces you to reassess what you're
doing
even just temporarily um and i think a
lot of times
you can choose to let it beat you down
or you can choose to turn that into like
fuel
and turn that into something to really
rev your engine and keep you going and
almost like
you know what you don't think i can do
it here we go let's make it happen let's
involve some other people if you don't
want to be involved all good
let's find some folks who are interested
and so
i think it's truly how you respond to
the situation
and sometimes like i'll be honest some
of my early films that got rejected i
took it a lot more personally
than i do if a film of mine gets
rejected now
because at first you're so connected to
your film because it's you know
your first short like you know you're
you're so happy that you got it made and
then you spent a bunch of money on film
festivals that you got from
working your part-time job and then you
see that turn into a bunch of rejections
and then you're like oh man what's the
problem
and a lot of times you know the problem
isn't you the problem is you know
that film festival only has 20 slots and
they got like
a thousand entries and this year they're
programming films with this theme and
your film has a totally opposite theme
it doesn't mean your film's bad it just
means
it's not what they're looking for and so
you have to kind of zoom out a little
bit
and look at the goals of the film
festival or look at the goals of the
distributor and like what they're trying
to do not just you know
your own little isolated bubble of your
film and kind of realize there's
a much broader industry and a much
broader world out there
um that your film just may not fit into
and that's okay and like
a lot of times like i said earlier you
need to learn
when to leave a film on the floor and
just be like hey i'm done with it
i'm proud i learned my lesson but at
this point
i don't know what else i can get from
that so let's move on and let's do
something else
i know you've mentioned that a lot and i
think that's interesting about leaving
knowing when like okay this got this
many views and i'm good i finished it
i've submitted it this many times
when did you learn that lesson when did
you realize
this is when it's time to walk away from
this one i think it was after
the distribution of some of clowns it
was recent i mean this is like 2016 so
not super long time ago
uh it was just kind of seeing like man
we worked so hard like seriously we
worked so
hard to make this indie feature in north
carolina
and then we did the film festivals and
then we put it out and it definitely got
like a
like for a first film a nice little
modest viewing
and then after that it kind of teetered
off a little bit and i was like man
what's wrong what's happening and then i
thought a little more and i said well
this is
step one you know this is not step 100.
this is just the first step on the rung
of ladder
and uh you know the latter is long
there's there's not
a need to focus on this first step so
much and it was kind of zooming out
and it was able to say you know hey
is this film serving me anymore you know
i'm still you know obviously always
going to be attached to it i love the
film
you know films my baby like i love
making these projects and
it's always funny like to revisit them
years and years later because it's
almost like watching something
like i don't really watch my own films
but like occasionally i'll like go back
and be like
five ten years later i'll be like what
did that happen you know what is that
looking like now
and you watch it and you're like oh man
this is like such a
crucial lesson because i never would
have done it now in that way i did it
then
but that's the point it's like it got
you to where you are now
and i think it's able to teach you
something and i think that's the point
you know it doesn't need to be
you know any any more complicated than
that
you